hello metaphysical milkshakers it's me
Rayne Wilson and it is ireza Aslin
today this week really super excited to
be speaking to this incredible
young psychic guy Tyler Henry I want to
learn about the life of a medium but I
also want to learn about grief because
that's gets at the root of why he does
what he does you know anything having to
do with like communicating with people
on their side have to do with grief but
um what are your thoughts on Grief have
you experienced any grief recently you
your family anything like that
you know I yeah I got a complicated uh
relationship with grief I guess I don't
know if I've um
ever truly
grieved or felt grief uh had a weird
thing you know my my uh one of my sons
had a bird and you know can I get one of
your chickens or no not one of our many
many chickens like an actual uh it
wasn't a parrot but it was kind of like
a parrot it was a a very very smart
sophisticated bird when we bought him at
the store the uh the store owner
basically said hey yeah this this uh you
could have conversations with this bird
and I was like wow that's so great uh
how do we how do we do that it's like
you know just uh easy spend maybe 30 to
90 minutes a day uh with him I was like
30 to 90 minutes a day
that's barely how much time I spend with
my kids I think 30 to 90 minutes a day
with the bird welcome to metaphysical
Milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of Life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
[Music]
but whatever we got the bird and my boy
you know absolutely fell in love with
him
and then uh you know it was like four or
five years but uh he just died and oh
boy rain hope Yeah Boy uh my son
my son grieved in a way I've never seen
people grieve he grieved in a way like a
a b movie actress in the 30s would
grieved
like chest pounding God why yeah and
Alex tragedy yeah and you know like this
is what was like my weakness as a dad I
just stood there I didn't know what to
do I I honestly didn't know how to
respond I was trying you know not to I
felt uncomfortable I didn't I you know I
didn't know thank God my wife Jessica
stepped in you know she actually has you
know normal humanized and she knew to
hug him yeah
all of that like human stuff human
things exactly what you were like you
might do not know how to process this
uh but it was so strange for me because
I was like where did he get this because
that's not me I don't I that's not how I
well I think we know where he got it
from that goes to the center of
something like I I I my dad passed away
a year and a half ago but other than
that I didn't have anyone that I was
really close to or family members that
passed away but growing up
I lost a lot of pets along the way and I
do think that pets are a good training
ground for this circle of life and the
grieving process too you know I was
about seven or eight years old and I had
these two gerbils I loved very much
Frederick and Nelson and anyone who's
from Seattle will understand that
reference and I took one outside and he
was kind of like running around on this
little patch of ground and he kind of
ran at me so I jumped up to kind of get
out of the way and then he ran under my
foot and I couldn't help it and I landed
on him
I landed on Nelson and crushed his
little gerbil skull and there was gerbil
blood coming out I was responsible for
his death that's murder it was I was
like seven eight years old I just
started to to weep my dad came out I
didn't know what to do he was thrashing
around and my dad grabbed him by the
tail and went in the other room and I
heard the toilet flush
so I didn't really get a sense of
closure with old Nelson but
there were several other pets that I
lost along the way and um I think
culturally it's very strange people get
so upset when dogs die and pets die it's
like we lost a family member and it's
like and but it kind of stops there and
it's like yeah you should grieve you
should cry it is sad they you know if
you get a dog you got eight to fifteen
years of good times and then it's gonna
die it's natural it happens on farms
animals are dying every single day
um so that people don't necessarily take
that next step of like and I hope you
close the loop with your son of like hey
guess what
we all are going to die just like what
was the bird's name
cracker
just like just like wait a second is
that kind of a racist yes
name I don't think he realized the
racism in the name but yeah I could see
that
hey cracker hey cracker
no you're absolutely right and this
brings up I think a larger point that we
want to tackle uh this week on the
metaphysical milkshake pod which is how
do we grieve what is grief uh you know
we I've experienced grief in a vastly
different way than than you have and I
mean what does that say you know in the
way that we think about
um grief as a process as a as an emotion
and you know we could have had a lot of
different guests come on and talk about
this because I had like a therapist or a
counselor or psychiatrist psychologist
maybe a doctor you know or a a war
Survivor or something yes a war Survivor
or my son but we thought we would do
something a little bit different on the
program today we have a medium Tyler
Henry medium to the Stars celebrity
medium
did you know that there was such a thing
as a celebrity medium rain
um you're a celebrity
I didn't know that I didn't know that
well does that mean they are famous or
they only do readings for famous people
I think in his case it's both Tyler
Henry uh is an author he identifies as a
clairvoyant uh that means his like
primary way of receiving information
from the Beyond is through Visions
images pictures uh he does these
readings where he connects people with
their loved ones who have passed uh he's
done this on TV uh he had a show on E
Hollywood medium with Tyler Henry that
was on for four seasons and now he's got
a new Netflix show life after death with
Tyler Henry uh and a brand new book
called here and Hereafter and so let's
talk about the grieving process with a
guy who talks to dead people because
that makes a lot of sense it does make a
lot of sense but I want to say celebrity
medium there's a list here of the so
celebrities I don't know if they qualify
as celebrities stop okay let's go
through some of these people I'm so
sorry no no no no no no no I'm gonna dig
into this
John Sally I vaguely remember he was a
basketball player Alan Thicke
are you kidding come on
was he oh he was on a sitcom in like the
80s or something
yeah it was uh um
okay
Safa
I don't know who some of these people
are and I don't think that uh I think
qualifying Tom Arnold and Jaleel Wright
as white as celebrities is is kind of
pushing the envelope here but
nonetheless
give them the benefit of the doubt he
wrote a great book let's bring him on
the show Tyler Henry
Tyler Harry thank you so much for
joining us on the metaphysical milkshake
pod so exciting to have you here did you
say Tyler Herbie I said Tyler Henry did
I did I swallow that
I it sounded like Tyler like Percy or
Tyler
yeah something it was some something
Tyler weird anyways it's Tyler Henry
you're a renowned medium psychic
television personality wise person and
kind of
guru-esque philosophers
wisdom way too much credit thank you
though and Hereafter is the brand new
book uh Tyler just let's just get right
into it what number am I thinking of
you I'm sensing between one and a
thousand oh my God somewhere in there oh
my God that's right there's a
statistical chance but yeah no no 18
637.
that's it and practically I'm
practically Harry Houdini uh no Okay so
we've introduced you as a medium you
talk about yourself as a medium you're
often described uh with that label and
I'm just curious uh what the hell does
that even mean like what is that looking
at the camera he looks like a medium
he does not look I think large would be
too drapey extra large definitely medium
short during the pandemic I actually
gained about 30 pounds so now I'm
actually a medium medium you did not if
you with an extra 30 pounds
wow give me to my 30s I'll get large and
then it'll be really ironic no seriously
tell us how should we think about what a
medium is you know like how do you think
about it do you are you okay with the
label do you like the label yeah I think
there are probably better terms that
exist I just think it's such a tricky
thing because medium is such an
encompassing term uh when I think of
what a medium is it really is defined as
an intermediary or someone who's in the
middle and so it's kind of a generic
term in the sense that that could apply
to a lot of things if people who act as
intermediaries religiously spiritually
personally I think religion very much
ties into that role of kind of people
taking on that mediumistic quality
themselves so there's a lot of
applications of it it's a very general
term but it just is somebody who
receives intuitive information with the
gold delivering it to other people
and the goal of delivering it to other
people with the purpose of what
validation and that's really the most
specific thing for me and when I do a
reading I have to be able to connect to
information that can't be researched
can't be guessed can't be gleaned from
someone's body language and when I go
into reading I never know what to expect
so I have to just try to give people
what I feel I'm meant to deliver I liken
my job to that of a mailman so I'm not
writing the letters I'm just delivering
the message and I think that's actually
a very practical way to understand what
a medium is we may not always know who's
giving us the messages
um or even what they are but it's the
role itself that a medium takes I'll
tell you why I like the the term
intermediary because
it the the idea of like an individual
who stands between two different planes
right the world of the living in the
world of the Dead this world and the
world Beyond or however you want to talk
about it this is something that exists
in all cultures all religions it goes
back to our prehistoric Paleolithic past
it's actually what the definition of
Shaman is the shaman is the individual
who can commune with both planes and and
communicate from one plane to the other
so I really like that idea of
intermediary though if I were you may I
suggest Clairvoyant because it just
sounds so it sounds so much more
sophisticated and it's a French word it
means Clear Sight and it is a way that
you know people sometimes receive
information but yeah it's a lot sexier
of a word than medium
so I have a story to tell you great can
I tell you a psychic story
um now psychic now how is medium
different than a psychic so I think all
mediums have a psychic ability but not
all psychics are mediums that's kind of
the distinction I make um we think of
psychic as typically referring to
telling the future I refer to really as
just anything extra sensory and mediums
doing what they do have to connect on
that extra sensory level so I consider
it a facet of a psychic ability but not
all psychics necessarily communicate
with the dead I hate to correct you
Tyler but I believe the plural is media
media Am I Wrong Am I Wrong about some
people call me medians and I'm like no
I'm not the thing in the middle of the
road
all right Ray tell us your tell us your
medium story which by the way I'm sure
is your favorite thing Tyler is when
people tell you medium stories they're
my favorite
my favorite how much people have in
common actually
you're gonna love this story so my wife
made friends with a psychic in Hollywood
I forget her name this was a long time
it's like almost 20 years ago and then
my friend Richard went and saw her and
she did a psychic reading and she's like
oh man
I'm getting just a big impression that
something with the letter A
and he's like no and he's like no with
the letter A like someone someone in
your life with a letter A someone is
like no you're not your mom dad someone
who passed away sister letter A nothing
it's like no nothing nothing is like
she's like I
I don't know what to say I'm just
getting the strongest impression of the
letter A
and I don't know what that means
two days later
he's working as a background actor for a
commercial shoot for Sotheby's
and they're like
auctioning off silly things like oh
here's a giraffe and they're auctioning
a giraffe and they're bringing out
different things and they're like okay
we need someone to hold this Greek
statue we need someone to lead this
giraffe and we um hear you and they
point to my friend Richard we need you
to hold this
and they hand him a gigantic letter A
and he spends the entire day two days
later after his reading holding an
enormous letter A all day long
that's bizarre how's that it's pretty
good right here's what I get from that
story celebrities can purchase giraffes
is that a thing big letters it is well
we have a zonkey you haven't seen my
donkey zebra hybrid I mean come on it's
like a badonka donkey no that's that's
more the after show all right all right
you but listen when you're getting
started as a medium uh Tyler how does
that work exactly like you're getting
started like before you became famous
Hollywood medium like did you have a
shingle out on you know Santa Monica
Boulevard with a neon sign that said
palmistry or did you get a bank loan you
have to go in the bank and say I I want
ten thousand dollars to start a medium
like literally how do you start that
business sure well for me I graduated
high school when I was 16 years old and
I had the goal at the time of trying to
become a hospice nurse so I enrolled in
Community College I was going down that
route I knew at that age that I had this
ability I just didn't really know how I
was going to apply it and so hospice
felt like a natural Synergy to be able
to be there for people who were dying
and their families but quietly I was
doing readings through word of mouth and
people would meet with me after class
and I would you know do readings for
them and at the time it was like 20 30
bucks and it was just to try to kind of
Meet the cost of textbooks and so I
didn't really think that it was going to
go anywhere but very quickly it did and
within a year I had people coming to my
front door where my mouth spread very
quickly and I actually ended up reading
the dean of the College of all people
and I ran into him one day and he
actually encouraged me to leave school
because he had such a profound
experience and he said you know you have
this ability I know it's real you should
really think about maybe using it uh and
so when the dean of the college tells
you to leave you know you kind of have
permission and so I did I left school
and I continued doing readings and by
the age of 19 I was offered a television
show so it was a very very short period
how do you go from doing readings this
was in Fresno oh this was near Fresno in
Hanford California yes okay so you're
doing you're doing readings at age 18 in
Hanford California how do you go from
that to TV show I'm sorry I just need to
connect the dots here yeah well he's
quite a handsome man I think no just you
know
I will say you know Southern California
is a lot more open-minded than where I
come from Central California a lot of
people don't know is agriculturally
based a lot of conservatism so I dealt
with a lot of religious pushback from
people who were you know more on the
fundamentalist side of things and so
while some people were open to what I
did in my small town others weren't and
very often people would meet with me
secretly they wouldn't tell their
husbands
um but all that to say I think the
demand started coming from Southern
California because people there
geographically are just a lot more open
to the creative Fields the spiritual at
least comparative to where I'm from and
so naturally I had a draw from there
before I knew it I was going to Southern
California my first celebrity client was
with Sarah Paulson uh of America and
Sarah Paulson was an incredible
experience for me as just a teenager but
that was my first celebrity reading and
then it kind of just evolved from there
but I always say the power of word of
mouth is an incredible thing if you're
real if you're able to give people
something validating you shouldn't have
to advertise
so you've used this phrase reading a
bunch of times what is that like how do
you conduct a reading like what happens
in a a uh a reading do you just kind of
like concentrate on the person and start
to get messages talk us through what
that actually looks like absolutely so
when I do a reading I scribble and
scribbling is really my methodology of
kind of turning on so that when I'm not
scribbling I can kind of turn off the
premise of that practice is really
repetition
um it's not the scribbles themselves
that have any significance as much as
it's the process of repetitively
scribbling back and forth we see that a
lot in other religions as well
repetition being something that helps
people get into an altered state of
consciousness sometimes transcendental
States I even think of within
Catholicism right you have the rosary
and people will pray it repeatedly
there's something about repetition that
just helps us get into a different state
of mind and scribbling is that for me
once I get into that kind of meditative
State I just basically have to focus on
any impression that come through and I
use the word impression because people
think of psychic abilities as like
seeing dead people walking around and I
wish it were that easy but it's really
not when I do a reading I just get these
little Impressions little Sensations
sometimes it'll feel like a memory
that's not mine sometimes it'll feel
like a song that's stuck in my head but
it might be a sentiment or an idea
um and then other times you'll even get
physical Sensations in my body that
correspond with how somebody passed so
the best way to understand it is really
to think of my body as kind of like a
canvas and the spirits that come through
I believe kind of paint the picture
using my senses to communicate what they
want to say
and of these messages in your you know
you're doing several readings a day I
imagine and you're getting you've you've
received thousands of messages from the
other side what's the most common
message that you've received in your
reading I would say one of the most
powerful messages universally across the
board is the importance of saying it now
while we still have the chance
um so many people that sit in the chair
across from me are sitting in front of
me because something is unresolved they
either have regret because something
went unsaid or something went undone and
that's even under the best case scenario
you know we have situations where people
will be ill for eight months and we know
they're gonna die and we have that
little send-off and even those are
difficult because people still wish they
would have done more in hindsight so for
me the greatest takeaway is the
importance of validating those
relationships in the here and the now
while we have the chance so that we can
prevent future regret so I live my life
differently as I go about my
relationships I ensure that I'm
communicating everything when I can
um and I just you know try to not go to
bed angry that's a famous quote but it's
true you know try not to go to bed angry
say it because you never know when you
won't have the chance to
yeah hey rain
I love you man what do you have to say
to me I love you man I love you that's
all oh I just feel like you know sweet
it's a Love Fest I want to say it now
I'm validated I want to say to you Reza
I like you
it's a slow burn
it's a sliver love is a strong word it's
a big commitment I'm not quite sure I'm
there yet like this is all very
fascinating because
I don't know I mean look rain and I were
talking about this uh before the the
podcast started and I'm not sure what I
believe it's hard like I mean
I have this whole Theory because I
believe in God and I have this theory
that if you're willing to believe in God
then you better be open to some pretty
[ __ ] crazy ideas
like I believe in God but ghosts that's
ridiculous sure you know so I am
definitely open but the truth is
so far our producer you know put
together all these uh fascinating data
points about American beliefs about the
Paranormal three out of four Americans
75 believe in paranormal phenomenon
nearly half of Americans believe in
ghosts like spirits that are among us
um and by the way this isn't just like
spiritual people or like mystically
minded uh people Thomas Edison very
famously uh in 1920 tried to create a
spirit phone like uh you know like a
phone except instead of talking to
living people you talk to dead people
and it wasn't because he was interested
in like spirituality or the spirit world
it's because he thought well you know we
can use science like science will prove
that there are you know these Spiritual
Beings Among Us so by the way that would
make an amazing horror film
um it really would they some one
discovers in Thomas Alva Edison's
Warehouse the spirit phone that he
created and they Crank It Up and it
actually works hold on I'm ready I'm
writing this down right now nobody else
here
I get 10 he gets ten percent we'll split
it three ways and also like you know
this is the other thing that I really I
really like about you know the way that
you talk and think about your
um abilities is that they're very
spiritual for you you I mean this is a
an expression of faith for you I was
reading in here and Hereafter that
you're you know you're constantly
talking about this is a a faith
expression what you do and I guess that
you know has partly to do the fact that
as you were just mentioning you will you
grew up in a very conservative Christian
environment uh you know I imagine
there wasn't a lot of acceptance I'm not
sure maybe there was uh for these
abilities that just kind of poured out
of you when you were a teenager tell us
a little bit about what that experience
was like sure well my first premonition
happened when I was 10 years old and
this would have been in April of 2006
and you know growing up I had a very
ordinary childhood grew up in this
conservative Community my parents have
been together for over 30 years and I'm
an only child so I got all the attention
as a kid but everything was pretty
normal for me until 10
um I basically just woke up one night
and I had this knowingness that my
grandmother was going to die and at the
time it just felt like a memory that
hadn't happened yet and I was really
confused and as I went to try to explain
this to my mom her phone rang and as she
picked it up it was the news from my dad
that he had just watched my grandmother
die in front of him so that was really
the Catalyst but at 10 years old that
wasn't recognized as an ability it was
just a moment of knowingness it was just
an intuition which is something we all
have so my mom didn't write recognize
that as something that I could do over
and over and over again and nor did I
but it took years of these kind of
moments of epiphany
um to kind of realize that there was
something more going on in my personal
belief I think intuition and Epiphany
are directly related and a lot of what
people kind of attribute to being as aha
moments might be intuition you said this
it kept happening again and again yes
how is your mom responding to that as it
was happening again and again I you know
on one hand I think she thought okay
maybe Tyler just has a big imagination
but the difference was was as I would
share things with kids at school and
they would validate them as being
correct such as talking about that a
kid's parents just had an argument
before school or I would talk about
family members of kids that was around
and for some it was like oh that's cool
and then other people were kind of
afraid of me but this got back to my mom
and she ultimately had to make the
choice of either to accept it or not but
ultimately I was able to demonstrate
these moments of knowing this enough to
convince her and my dad ultimately as
well and from there they just kind of
grew to accept it for what it was I
think when we know better we can do
better and my parents are a great
example of that of loving your child
unconditionally no matter how different
they might be that's so wonderful to
hear what about the rest of the
community like the rest of the community
it was very divisive it was actually
very fascinating to see as Word of Mouth
spread about my ability I started
getting blamed for things that I never
did so in high school for example there
was this bully and he was a jock and he
broke a a bone while at a football match
and I got blamed for it in my high
school they thought I threw witchcraft
had caused his injury and then it was
one thing after another I would get you
know attributed to things that there's
no way obviously I could have been
responsible for but that goes to show
kind of the dangers of superstition and
it might sound funny coming from a
medium but I actually think it's
important that we Embrace logic and
critical thinking and the scientific
method
um and not allow Superstition to dictate
Our Lives because if we do
it becomes like the Salem Witch Trials
all over again so wow it might be a
weird take coming from the source but
that's what I'm believable that's
fascinating I never thought I'd be in an
interview with a clairvoyant who would
say hey we need to be logical and and
use science and not be filled with
Superstition but I but I like that I
like what you're saying because I like
Reza and listeners know I also believe
in God and I believe in an afterlife and
I believe our our souls are essential
kind of humanness uh part of who we are
continues uh a journey through other
planes of existence Beyond this physical
world I mean why not the other idea just
makes zero sense to me that there's all
of this beautiful creation and
incredible Consciousness and then the
lights get turned out and that's the end
and there is only a physical plane of
existence uh it really doesn't make
sense to me but regardless the main
reason we really wanted you on the show
was we thought that you would have a
unique perspective on on Grief so
we wanted to ask a couple of questions
about grief about dealing with grief I
have mentioned before on the show my
father passed away about a year and a
half ago
that was the first close family member
that I'd ever lost and it was very
devastating
the thing I thought that was I found
very interesting about it was and I
still grieve him to this day a year and
a half later and don't do a re I don't
want to know what he's got to say by the
way I don't want to know anything no we
don't want that public I'm fine I'm fine
with I'm fine with him over there but
but a couple of things came up for me
one was I missed him so much and hurt my
heart so deeply to lose him I felt like
we had a good 10 or 15 years left to
connect his father and son that we
didn't get to do he died at 79. and I
also you know I had a difficult
childhood and I had some very real
resentments of the guy and he was really
not there for me in a lot of ways and
was a pretty lousy father in a lot of
ways too and kind of wrestling with both
of those was really
challenging of like wow I miss and love
you so much and still I had so much so
many unmet needs from you and I have
some resentments left and and we worked
this [ __ ] out and he knew how I felt and
I was there was nothing left unsaid
there but it was that really flavored
the grieving process and you
you say that your task is
for the people that you're meeting with
your clients is to bring hope and
healing and closure to people and
I'm this reminds me of my my stepmom my
dad's wife who really has a feeling of a
presence of him around and continues
conversations with him and I know lots
of widows that do this continue
conversations with their past ones and
sometimes I will sometimes I'll just
talk to him I don't know exactly if he's
hearing but I'll just speak from my
heart or just say you know I miss you
Dad and you know even ask for help or
guidance in some way to these people
let's just say widows for lack of a
better word this conversation this
ongoing conversation which is done by
about three quarters of them by the way
brings great Solace to them so how does
how do your readings how do your
connections how do these conversations
that you undertake how do they fit into
the grieving process and help people
with their healing and their closure
absolutely well you know I think when it
comes to grief that on some level grief
is the price that we pay for love
and I find reminders of that every day
in the work that I do but more than that
I find that grief is an ongoing process
we think of the word closure as being a
final process almost like a period at
the end of a sentence but my job has
taught me that the process of closure is
so much more than that it's more of a
comma it's ongoing and we have to
process all of these feelings that we
have about these people in our lives and
we take that with us as do they so I
think if anything you know people think
that grief
shrinks over time and I don't believe
that I think if anything we grow around
our grief it's like weight you know we
hold it in different places we carry
weight in different places and it's very
different depending on the person but
but but but more specifically so what
does this process I mean I've seen some
videos of you and people are crying and
you've obviously touched nerves and
they're able to process some grief but
how does the conversation heal it's a
release and I always say to people are
like Tyler is it weird when you make
people cry and I'm like no it's actually
a good thing it is a release it's a
representative of the fact that that
person is hearing something that is
bringing things to the surface that need
to be processed and just doing that can
sometimes be cathartic for a person it
can be intense but it can also leave a
person I believe transformed in a way
that was different than when they
initially sat down all that to say
though readings are not a cure for grief
a medium is not a cure for
all I believe I do is validate that
there is a connection that there is love
I believe the Consciousness continues on
but it's important that we honor that
physical loss even if we are a spiritual
person I think people think of it as you
know mediums don't grieve but we do so
you know it's it's kind of an
amalgamation of all those things it's
meant to validate that there's still
something there but it's never meant to
replace the that person is there a cure
for grief I don't think so I think grief
is one of those aspects of suffering
that is universal I think it's something
that we all will go through if we live
long enough or we will be grieved
ourselves uh so for me it's just kind of
one of those difficult truths in reality
I think while some spirituality might
want to just kind of erase grief I
actually am all about embracing grief as
a process something that is natural
something that even if you believe in
God in a higher power it's okay to still
cry it's okay to still want to pick up
the phone and call them want to give
them a hug being spiritual doesn't make
all of that better if that makes sense
well even Jesus wept shortest sentence
in the Bible Jesus there you go
absolutely is this what is often meant
when we talk about the difference
between grief and grieving that like
grief is that emotional state that just
like tears you up you know it just comes
over you unexpectedly like a wave just
you know leads you devastated
but grieving is this kind of forever
process right it's a thing that you just
carry with you forever it transforms the
way that you think about the world is
that kind of like what you're talking
about absolutely you know grief puts us
in a liminal State and liminal states
are defined as threshold States and they
typically occur very often when someone
goes through a big life change where we
are thrust into transition and
familiarity is lost so think of like
divorce illness the death of a loved one
that is very transformational that puts
us in a liminal State and liminal states
by definition are transformative so as
difficult as they are as disorienting as
they are the limit liminality of life is
where we get the most information those
times in our lives when we have nothing
secure to hold on to when familiarity is
lost and when we are basically just
feeling like we're having to fend for
ourselves that very often is where we
see a lot of growth in people's lives
but I also just think it's an Evidence
ability of life I don't think we can
eliminate liminality nor should we
um that's just my thoughts on it
first of all I just want to say I love
this idea this definition grief is the
price we pay for love that's so
so good and I also really like what
you're saying about how the grieving
process
you know as as a experience of
liminality is is fundamental to you know
our understanding of who we are you have
this whole thing in the book that you
say early on in the I think in the in
the introduction or prologue where you
you say that
your experience of being a medium and
being in communion you know with people
who have passed
um has actually helped you understand
the universe and your place in it and I
wonder I mean not all of us obviously
have the ability that that you have but
in grieving
it's the closest we come in a way right
to
communing with the other side
um I mean maybe maybe for us it's a
one-way Street not a two-way street the
way it is for you but
in a way
that little touch that we get you know
of the of the other side
uh helps us to understand what it means
to be human so like grieving can be a
fundamental part of the human experience
a a thing that that you that you
actually want to experience right and I
to that point I think it's because it's
an inevitability there's aspects of this
where we can either choose to embrace it
or reject it but either way it's going
to happen and so in my work I've seen
when it comes to how we can best move
forward through grief the best thing I
can just say is to try to honor those
who have died through your actions you
will never be able to introduce that
loved one that you cared about to new
people to new members of family but you
can introduce the love that they gave
you or even in rain's case maybe some of
the challenges that were presented in
that relationship you can learn from
that and then you can extend those
lessons to other people that are alive
in your life and in that way that is an
afterlife that they get when they can
make a difference in our lives we can
take the initiative and kind of
introduce their
through our actions there's something
almost alchemical about that to me uh in
how the loss of somebody actually can
sometimes make us more whole
I'm curious Wayne why do you not want
Tyler
to do a reading
just I mean you know whatever like I'm
just I'm just curious about it
because I don't want to cry okay that's
okay absolutely
no that's that is there's some truth to
that but
I guess because for me I do have closure
like
um
I got to be with him he was going in for
a
quadruple bypass surgery we knew there
was a chance he wouldn't make it I got
to spend the hours before he went in
with him together
I got to pray with him when he was on
life support
and
you know and I and I've fully grieved I
also really believe in the process of
not just grief when someone dies but
listen we live in a culture Tyler when
you agree that doesn't know what to do
about death or how to talk about death
that's for sure when it's the one thing
that we all share and and doesn't know
what to do with or how to talk about
grief and loss so death death and grief
and loss are uh just sewn into the
fabric of life and I I feel like I had
my process and I feel good about it and
I still
pray for the progress of my father's
soul I still connect with my father so
I'm it's kind of like I'm good and I
hope I'm saying that not out of some
kind of denial like uh well that's not
something that I that I would uh need
necessarily yeah and that's the thing
not everybody needs a reading and not
everybody needs to see a medium and
that's one of those beautiful things
where if we can get to a place in our
own grief where we at least are content
I think that's a really beautiful thing
so so I've got this kind of I mean
weirdly opposite thing my my father died
five years ago
um
and uh
I mean it's
I don't think I ever really grieved
about it and it's not like I kept myself
from grieving you know my wife
to this day still brings it up sometimes
and I
I have delved deep into my soul
searching for the grief and I loved my
father very much I mean we weren't you
know uh incredibly tight
um but you know I I recognize all that
he did for me and and you know the the
way that he he loved me the best that he
could and and all that he sacrificed for
me and sort of leaving uh Iran and
coming here with nothing and starting
all over again and and he had a kind of
a it was like a quick it was a slow
demise that then very then became a
quick demise you know it often happens
um so it's not like his death was
surprising
um
but I don't know how to describe it I
mean I think about grief as the price we
pay for love and I was like well I don't
really grieve and I never and I I don't
think I ever really did grieve my
father's passing what is that does that
say that I didn't love him I'm confused
help me out I think of it as like a
weight right and we all carry weight
differently and there's a reason I say
it that way some people grief looks like
sobbing into their hands every single
day for years I've sat with clients
who've lost loved ones sadly who it may
have been a decade ago and you would
swear it's just as fresh as it was you
know when it first happened so I think
everyone carries it differently there's
no shame in not being devastated by the
loss of somebody if anything I think
that gives us an upper hand in being
able to remember their lives and honor
their lives more meaningfully from what
I can take from those who've
communicated with me they want us when
we think of them to not Define their
whole life by a single moment of death
and it sounds like incredible from wrong
but you're at a place where you can
think about that whole long life and
your relationship and I'm sure it had
some highs and some lows but you're okay
you're content on some level with how
that happened and so I don't think you
know it's indicative that you don't love
your father it's just indicative that
you're carrying that grief differently
than maybe somebody who loses a child or
maybe somebody who didn't have you know
that contentedness towards the end so
one of the biggest messages there's no
real right or wrong way to grieve as
much as I think we can't lay down and
die and it's important that we have
support systems resources no matter
where we are in our grief to be able to
feel okay with where we're at Tyler your
book is called how wisdom from The
Departed can transform your life now
sometimes can you give us
the
what is it can you give us a sneak peek
how would you boil down
how this wisdom
from The Departed can transform your
life and does it relate to grief
absolutely so I always say that in all
the readings I've done the one thing
that I'm certain of
is that there is something along the
lines of a Life review process and every
single person that comes through to me
seems to be some version of themselves
that seems a little bit more in the know
or more aware than they were when they
were here I attribute this to a process
that I think Consciousness goes through
when we die it's a process of expansion
in which we see the ripple effect of how
every action and inaction affected the
greater collective in life unfortunately
we are limited to our one perspective
our one body and that often is kind of
all we can really fully understand but I
believe that when they die they get this
kind of interconnection in a way that
allows them to empathize and understand
what was important in life and what
wasn't what was worth focusing on what
never was and I think that gives these
consciousnesses a sense of clarity and
ultimately an acceptance around how they
lived and how they died and that's when
we talk about finding peace on the other
side I believe that's kind of the end
game is being able to come to a place of
full acceptance
um all of that to say that this gives
people a very immense understanding of
the importance of taking the initiative
when given the opportunity to not you
know withhold saying things doing things
ensuring that we are validating each
other in the here and the now and I
think if anything you know when it comes
to mediums people sit with me because
they have regret and if we can do
certain things and live in a certain way
we can at least minimize the chances of
us having regret in the future so that
for me is really what it's all about I
want people to read that book and not
have to go run off to a medium and maybe
validate those who are still with them
so that we have the best chance possible
of having a sense of contentedness when
the time comes that we do lose somebody
but but I love how you're framing it
because what you're talking about is
self-help living your best self is
living a life that you're not going to
feel that regret when you die when you
do that Life review when you feel like I
did what I could with what I had and any
anything that we can do in our daily
practice our spiritual practice to
remind us of that fact it brings us into
greater Consciousness I I love that
you're taking the reader in that
direction do the Life review while
you're still alive right exactly and it
kind of ties into Carl Young's concept
of individuation which I am a huge
proponent of and I believe that
Consciousness is on the other side go
through this individuation process I
think they become more of themselves
just as in life I think we are all
gradually every day becoming more of who
we are and we should strive to be more
of ourselves I think there's a lot of
power in that idea Tyler uh I don't know
I'm suddenly nervous I'm a little bit
nervous about this I have to say like
gee I mean I'm I'm kind of open if you
want to do a reading of me I guess I've
never I've never had one I can tell you
right now I've never I've never had
anything like it at all and I don't want
to put you on the spot no no I totally
get it what I need typically as a
notepad and a pin and usually about an
hour so what we can do is that's the
only downside typically it takes a
little time to get into it okay well
maybe maybe we do it later and then I
report on it cool
I love that okay I famously don't
experience emotions the way most humans
do uh I think I've cried
uh
[Music]
uh four times in the last
30 years wow you know wow
not that I'm like I try not to it's not
like I'm like I will not cry but it it
goes back to the The Grieving thing you
know I I can theoretically like when I
think about
God heaven forbid anything happening to
my wife or or my children like I I can
barely breathe
but
yeah but when I think about sort of you
know the people that I've lost in the
way that I grieved them
it's like I'm I'm searching for
something that's not there I keep
digging and digging and digging and like
it's got to be there somewhere but then
it's not and then I think to myself well
maybe there's just something wrong with
me I don't know
even though how the grief process even
though it involves the death of other
people how much it teaches us about
ourselves right and I mean obviously
there was a lot of love there and
there's nothing wrong with how you're
grieving but it's just fascinating how
it brings all those things to the
surface and that really speaks I think
to kind of the liminal nature of grief
anytime we go through liminal
experiences they bring stuff up to the
surface that we gotta look at and you
know for better for worse that that's
kind of the benefit at least it lets us
kind of focus on what we need to focus
on at that time Tyler Henry uh this has
been such a fascinating look and
honestly I
I've never really thought about grief in
these terms and it and uh and I've never
even really thought about the idea of
you know the connection to the afterlife
in these terms you know the notion of
truly experiencing Life by connecting to
the afterlife is is it's just a
beautiful way of thinking about it I'm
I'm totally totally grateful for this
conversation
likewise and rain if you ever want to
read it I'm always here of course free
of charge for both you and I would love
to connect if you're ever ready so
offers always withstanding I Want to See
You Weep yeah just burst into tears be
very stoked it might get caught in his
beard
oh and he's holding there you go I Cry I
Cry easy I cry at the drop of a hat so
the book is here and here after it's
available now and the Netflix series
which is available for streaming right
now is called life after death uh and
you know fingers crossed for a season
two uh because you know there's a lot of
life and death to talk about no shortage
there it just keeps happening do you
think do you think you'll give readings
to people when you're on the other side
what would that look like yeah that's a
good question I wondered before if
guides on the other side which is talked
about extensively in spiritualism
literature if like those guides maybe
weren't mediums in this life who knows
it's a theory what happens when a bunch
of mediums get together oh there's
conferences mediums are such
anti-structural people by Nature so they
very rarely get along fully we're
usually kind of like loners it's a very
interesting thing there's a lot of
patterns among anti-structural people
and you see it in medium s for sure you
talked about the Life review process you
talked about the ever-expanding
Consciousness which I relate to because
I've been thinking about human
consciousness you know a baby in the
womb has a certain measure of
Consciousness they can recognize light
heat sound movement
Etc then a baby and Consciousness isn't
just there when we're born it grows and
develops I have a teenage son I get to
see with him every three or four months
like new forward steps in his
Consciousness as he grows into adulthood
I think the point is to increase our
Consciousness you know I I would say
Consciousness is kind of set when we're
in our early 20s but we want to grow
that through to our 80s or 90s and we
want to continue that process on the
next side but what happens after we die
Tyler the Life review process and the
ever-growing Consciousness it's
obviously some kind of plane that's a
little bit above and beyond time and
space right there non-linear it's
non-physical but what else can you tell
us about the other side is anytime I've
tried to get answers on like who is the
right God or is there a heaven or a hell
they liken it to trying to explain
arithmetic to a squirrel and I'm the
squirrel in this equation and it's not a
cop-out as much as it's really just to
say I think we as human beings are so
limited in what we can understand about
this realm let alone the next but that
to say I do think that the other side
when they come through they acknowledge
that whatever process they're going
through it's experiential it doesn't
seem to come through as a physical place
it seems to be based or rooted in
experiential Consciousness
expansion of awareness interconnection
and really kind of superseding one's ego
um all of that to say I don't even
necessarily know what all that means or
what it implies or what that could
indicate as far as our purpose goes it's
just more of these observations that
I've made through time so I genuinely
don't have the answer I think it's part
of the great mystery of life it's
beautiful in and of itself
do you think they do anything up there
over there you know they don't like do
they have like jobs you're creating
things you know it doesn't come through
in that way but who's to say they don't
you know I try to be open-minded but I
also am not afraid to say I don't know
all right I don't know well I'm not
afraid to say that I don't know
how we're gonna end this podcast but I
will say Tyler this has been an absolute
pleasure
um I love your yours forgive my using
the word your spirit uh we were
complimenting your writing of This Book
Is So Exquisite and um it's been such a
pleasure having you on the show thank
you
foreign
Hey listen
um checking back in with you here at the
tail end of this podcast because we need
to error the Tyler Henry podcast but we
haven't gotten our
our sessions yet we haven't gotten our
readings yet what gives what's going on
well uh I I did want to tell you this
earlier but I did meet with Tyler he did
uh communicate with my uh uh dead father
and uh my father did have a message for
me it was that he wanted me to tell you
to be nicer to me
uh so that's from the beyond that
weighed us all right I'm lying no listen
folks uh it's
I am basically in line to see Tyler
Henry I I think I had this idea that
like as an important podcaster
that I would just basically end the
podcast and then like go to his house
and have him do a reading and he was
like yes I'm sorry you are 200th
in line for a reading and I was like I'm
sorry what now there are 200 people in
front of me well here's what I love
about the Tyler Henry organization is
they don't prioritize uh celebrities
yeah that was kind of nice which is
really cool so if he's met a dishwasher
who wants a psychic reading he they go
in that line of 200. yeah we'll put at
the end and they don't like whisk
Gwyneth Paltrow to the front of the line
I was gonna I was thinking about pulling
at Rayne Wilson and being like do you
know who I am do you know who I am I
mean like get me into the phone so folks
uh sad to say that this uh this reading
uh has not happened yet which I I'm not
gonna pretend that I'm like bummed about
like I'm I'm kind of nervous about it
I'm a little bit like I'm not exactly
sure you know as we talked about during
the interview I haven't really I don't
think processed my
uh the death of my father even though
it's been like I don't know a while it's
been like almost coming up on eight
years or something I was a little bit
nervous about it so it'll happen it'll
happen eventually
you know maybe I'll maybe I'll tweet
about it
but uh but it has not happened just yet
well when it does happen well you must
get this information out there and share
with people I'm really I'm really
excited to see how that goes folks uh
listen as we sometimes do here at
metaphysical milkshake we're going to be
giving away some copies of Tyler's new
book here and Hereafter so the first
five people that write a review for
metaphysical milkshake on Apple podcasts
email us a screenshot of that review it
could be good it could be bad we're open
we're open I mean the bad ones might go
to the bottom of the pile but
nonetheless you can write us always at
metaphysical at cast media that's cast
with a K metaphysical castmedia.com the
first five will be sent a copy of
Tyler's amazing book what an incredible
human being and if you have any life big
questions you can always of course find
us on social media at Reza Aslan and at
Rayne Wilson we're also on Twitter at
metamilk podcast and on Instagram at
metaphysical milkshake you can also
please remember to follow rate and
review metaphysical milkshake on Apple
podcasts or wherever else you listen to
podcasts and you can subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake YouTube channel
watch our full episodes every week see
how extraordinarily handsome Tyler Henry
actually is otherwise we will see you
next week unless we're dead then only
Tyler will see us next week only only
Tyler will be able to I wonder if we
could have a podcast
from the great beyond
and Tyler could
interpret it for the listener I will say
at this point the only people who don't
have a podcast are dead people so it
seems like the next natural that's the
next question yeah yeah absolutely
thanks for listening everybody
see you next week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rain Wilson Reza Aslan and
Colin Thompson it is produced by Safa
samasade Harris Lane Mick damaria Hashem
South and DJ lubel cast media is the
production and distribution partner
original music by Jeff Tang
foreign
[Music]
I just assumed you know I left the drag
at home I did not present his media
today but it's an honor to me he is a he
is a Master of Disguise and sometimes he
dresses like a you know mid-20s white
guy
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
YouTube channel thank you